dr. Ann shooked principal deputy
director of the Centers for Disease
Control joins us now from CDC
headquarters in Atlanta dr. shooked good
morning thanks for being here a pleasure
as as we just heard Nancy Cordes allude
to there's there's some mixed message of
the messages that seem to be coming at
us on the coronavirus on the one hand
you've got the White House saying it's
tightly contained and you've got the CDC
saying the spread of the virus here is
inevitable what are we supposed to make
of this you know it could be a confusing
time right now as we've seen the corona
virus spread in China and now in a
number of other countries the good news
is that here in the United States the
virus is contained with an aggressive
approach we've been able to keep the
numbers down only 14 cases detected
through our public health system and
medical system and 43 other cases
detected among people repatriated from
hotspots in China or on the cruise ship
but as we see outbreaks in Italy in Iran
in South Korea we need to be prepared in
case things change here doctor shook it
your if and when scenario was a little
unsettling for a lot of people because
you said it's not a matter of if it's a
matter of when do you have a timetable
in mind and are you concentrating on a
certain part of the country we really
need to be ready everywhere we've seen
in other outbreaks that there can be
what's called a popcorn pattern where
one community has an outbreak and
another doesn't you can see that that's
what's occurring in Italy right now
northern Italy has more disease that
we're not really seeing it in other
parts so we cannot predict exactly where
there may be community transmission we
can't say for sure if we will get
community transmission but based on what
we're seeing in Europe and the Middle
East we think it's more likely than we
thought a week or two ago doctor when
you talk about the approach what
specific steps is the CDC taking to
prevent a wider outbreak here in the US
we have been working aggressively on a
border strategy at airports and on
strategy with clinicians to detect
individuals who have this virus early
and to manage them appropriately we've
learned a lot in the last few weeks
about the
iris it doesn't seem to be as severe as
we first feared but it does seem to be
quite transmissible and some people have
very mild symptoms or possibly even no
symptoms at all hearing you say that the
screening is in place for people who are
coming here what about people who might
have already been infected and who are
already here what about those people
absolutely one of the things we're doing
is increasing what we call community
surveillance so that we can find cases
earlier so that we understand whether
there already is virus circulating
that's been undetected who is most at
risk for getting infected by coronavirus
based on what we know so far
the severe cases are primarily occurring
in the elderly in adults with chronic
conditions like diabetes or chronic lung
disease we haven't seen disease to any
great extent in children and that's a
difference with seasonal flu or other
influenza one of the big drivers of our
flu outbreaks each year is the high
rates of illness in children but we
haven't seen that with this virus
something we're on the lookout for but
that hasn't been detected so far all
right dr. Ann shook it with the CDC
thanks so much for being with us this
morning it was my pleasure